an suzuki was one of the world's most
famous political prisoners now she's a
beloved politician in Myanmar she helped
the country restore democracy after 62
years of British colonial rule three
years of Japanese occupation and another
50 years under the rule of an oppressive
military junta and she did it while
being locked in her home this is how a
political prisoner won the esteem of the
international community got elected
leader of her country and is now at risk
of losing the respect of the world
[Music]
and since uchi was born in 1945 in
Rangoon
now Yangon to Buddhist bar my parents
Myanmar's dominant ethnic group that
makes up nearly 70% of the population
her father and son was a general who led
the push to end British colonial rule in
1947 during the executive council
meeting to discuss a transition to
independence a group of gunmen burst in
and opened fire
no one knows exactly who sent this
government but they shot dead seven or
eight people one of them was uncertain
sue Chi's father's she was only 2 years
old at the turn that's bloomberg editor
jason katsu cos I'm the Southeast Asian
government editor for Bloomberg News
after the death of her father the
country completed the transition to
become a democratic republic with the
official name union of Burma when she
was 15
Suchi moved to new delhi after her
mother was appointed ambassador to india
after finishing high school she went to
Oxford University where she studied
philosophy politics and economics she
graduated in 1968 and moved to New York
City where she worked at the United
Nations in 1972 she married British
academic Michael Aris they had two sons
later returning to England one of the
conditions uncensored she had said at
the start of the marriage was if ever
she felt that a country needed her she
would go back
in 1988 sushi did return to Burma our
town mother suffered a stroke while
there she became involved with a student
protest movement that was rising up
against the military regime together but
keep out of politics yeah this movement
was was was building he could say which
way that it was blowing it wasn't just
luck she just happened to be there yeah
this was definitely something that she
always felt deeply about the liberation
leaders daughter tapped her father's
contacts and formed a political party
the National League for Democracy soon
afterwards she was elected at
secretary-general seen as a threat to
the junta soon she was put under house
arrest and there she stayed for almost
15 of the next 21 years her husband died
in 1999 while she was locked up
she received the international media
when she was under house arrest and she
was very successful in creating a brand
she's one of those real standout figures
from the 1980s and 1990s who won a Nobel
Peace Prize propelled by international
pressure the government finally released
sushi on November 13th 2010 by these
later NLD swept to power in elections
because she finally took charge of the
country
constitutionally barred from becoming
president for being the mother of
foreigners a provision apparently
inserted by the military specifically
targeting her Suchi instead took the
title of state councilor I think that
it's probably no longer applicable to
say she's the de facto leader of Myanmar
because in practice she's really is the
leader of the country her popularity and
authority has not been questioned until
now the Nobel Peace Prize she won in
1991 while under house arrest was for
her nonviolent struggle for democracy
and human rights
although the scope of her control over
the military is unclear she's facing
calls from petitioners to be stripped of
the award for not doing enough to stop
the repression and force exodus of the
reinga a muslim minority living near the
Bangladesh border more than 600,000
rahaga have fled into bangladesh since
August the United Nations is called an
ethnic cleansing
while SUCI and the military say they are
seeking to root out terrorists I think
there is a sense of bewilderment among
most people in Myanmar at the response
to the Rohini crisis they see the rain
years of people who don't belong in
their country and they just cannot
understand why Myanmar has been
criticized so harshly overseas Suchi is
resisting growing international pressure
to denounce the alleged human rights
abuses committed against the Ranga
instead she's showing a more ruthless
determination to hang on to power no
matter what cost her her international
reputation the government has been
making every effort to restore peace and
stability and to promote harmony between
the Muslim and Rakhine communities she's
come down decisively in favour of
majority public opinion on this issue
that's one of the reasons she's remained
so popular at home throughout this
crisis
the same global audience that
transformed her into a political star is
now demanding she take a stand
this Security Council in the United
Nations takes strong and swift action to
bring this crisis to an end whether she
can stem the tide of international
condemnation and once again become a
symbol of human rights remains to be
seen